well let's pull up this next story
because it's good news um actually john
do you want to explain what's going on
with this so
i reported this and you know the media
people are all like oh she's going
nowhere joy reid is out well not
officially yet but
comcast doesn't like her the people
roberts and the people at the top don't
like her and i got wind of something
that was said that you know
they're gonna use and i said this to
somebody that if you noticed the last
few days you saw her ratings being
leaked out as far as she's had the
lowest ratings and whatever but she's
just becoming offensive to everyone and
it's becoming offensive to advertisers
there's a lot of advertisers who are
balking you know there's only so many
times you can say that you know elon
musk bought it because he wants
apartheid back like you can say that
white people did x y and z but if you
just start using it as an example for
everything
you just you start to become offensive
to mostly even even black people find
her offensive many of my black friends
you know find many people i've talked to
find her offensive she's
she does comparable to don lemon but
that's not saying much yeah well
neither of those people are probably
going to be around for the long term i
mean take a look at this this is uh
tuesday's ratings
in the key demo this is
fascinating
joyri with 130 000
uh against burnett with 170 anderson
cooper with 170 don lemon with 136 and
then 116. jake tapper with 140 and 159
blitzer 152.
that's remarkable
because
we do better than that yeah oh
absolutely now you look you look at
waters 368 look at carlos oh yeah it's
not even close
i've looked at these ratings for 15
years and nothing changes fox stays
where it is and and msn and you know for
a long time cnn wanted to be msnbc
because they were beating them and then
they decided no that's two to the left
and then trump came along and you can't
be what you're not wasn't tucker carlson
on msnbc no he was on cnn he used to be
a cnn show yeah he was but he was on
msnbc yes oh yeah yeah i mean
if you combine anderson cooper from cnn
and um chris hayes and msnbc you combine
their ratings it is still almost 300 000
viewers less than fox sometimes triples
them combined like it's not even a
contest
you know there's media reporters who
keep asking like at msnbc they're giving
rachel maddow millions of dollars to do
nothing she does one show a week now and
now has special projects good for her
because yeah because they don't know
what to do with her what happened with
joey reads a fun story and that it
revolves a lot around
what happened with george floyd and it's
a basic narrative and that is they're
you know you al sharpton's those types
of people who have used race as a way to
continue to make money and
she used it as a way to keep her job
because everyone at msnbc is terrified
of her and everyone at nbc universal is
terrified of her on the other hand
people at comcast who see now there's
also other things coming and speaking of
someone we've talked about earlier
there's lawsuits coming about things she
has said about people and and so forth
and we saw what happened with the
covington kids as far as you know how
that went for cnn and others and she has
said some things equal about people that
are coming down the pike all in all
she's just not a a positive light for
the network and there she's made and
that whole gay thing has come back to
haunt her in ways that i don't think
she's quite well you can never survive
on the left man there oh but see you're
okay if you're on the if you're on the
left and you say something like that
you're like oh it was hacked okay move
on if you're on the right they would
want to see the forensics of it before
you'd get your show back and that's sort
of part of my concern with what we were
discussing earlier about elon musk
potentially unveiling some
sketchiness or potential fraud with
twitter's code is that i think it would
end up being the same kind of stories we
got with hillary's emails everyone would
know that there was foul play and
nothing would be done about it and it
would just sort of be waved away i do
also want to mention however that we're
looking at wallace's numbers tappers
numbers uh even maddow's numbers i'm
honored to say that i once did a cartoon
that was a parody of a news show and it
was literally just people farting and it
got more views
than they did of course and it was
called the dangers of political
extremism
this is important this is the key demo
we're not winning against cnn when it
comes to
old people no so if you look uh this is
this is a what do we got here 25 to 54.
for us i believe around 80
of our viewers are 18 to 54. their
average viewer is 68. 69. so you look at
this
cnn when you do all viewers they say 25
to 54. rest assured cnn is not getting
500 600 000 viewers from 18 to 24. right
and there's no more airport video of
them so these are people probably in
institutions or places they can't change
the channel because i don't know any 18
year olds watching cnn yeah i want to
see what their engagement is because
they just have the tv show they have a
tv on from four o'clock to ten o'clock
and they just let it run when they're in
the other room how old is uh rachel
maddow
she's gotta be in her late forties or
fifties by now it's it's it's a yeah
and and uh how old is tucker
tucker's
fifties
1973. so she's 47 40. it's really quite
amazing um
it's a strange it's a strange thought
for me the people who typically are like
yo hey i know who you are you're tim
poole when they greet me on the street
or whatever same it ages me of course
millennials uh often a lot of people who
look like they're mid to late 20s i
couldn't imagine being someone like
maddow and you go outside and young
people don't know who you are and then
you see some old person like hey you're
rachel man i'm a big fan so it's either
like the super view of your cartoon
i bet it's a girl with the pink hair and
the purple hair will come up to her or
people who are invested in the
now in the script even those far lefties
though even those progressive types who
are just completely wrong about
everything even they don't like legacy
media i watch twitch streamers who have
a left-handed perspective that's that's
true like you know hassan
young people are going to know who he is
i know who he is tucker carlson with
nearly six hundred thousand in the key
demo yeah he's gonna go outside and
young people are gonna be they know who
they know who he is they know he is
because he speaks to people like he
speaks you know you guys have to take on
the rest of this world and i think he
speaks to people who will care about
what's happening in the country and i
think you know mata gets incredible she
got her ratings were
fox-esque during certain like the whole
uh you know mueller
those types of things where people and
that shows you where we are as a country
because they're watching as a sporting
event they want their team trump to go
down they want him muller to come up and
say i got him and that's all they're
watching it for yeah she almost she
almost cried oh yeah well famously
mediate uh i'm not sure you can see it
on the side anymore but
a famous abc journalist cried the night
that trump got elected
um and
he called her out later um
in in one of the first times he met them
but yeah there was a lot of people
invested i mean that night was
surreal just of how many people were sad
something happened
in like 2015 to 2016.
you know in this period where people's
brains just distract it well it was that
moment it was like ben what's his name
outside the hillary event ben rhodes
where he's just sitting there that video
of him just sitting there going i i
don't know what happened it's a famous
video right after she gives her a
concession speech and he's just like
blindsided and and it's famous because
no one really knew what to say because
one side of you were like wow i voted
for him but do you think he's good
insane and the other side of you was
like yeah you know and
i watched a lot of young people feel
really happy about the future and you
know plus i think the mood of the
country was they were sick and tired
of the establishment i want to mention
this too it's not just joy right james
corden is quitting the late late show
yeah yo the machine is falling apart
well also late night shows used to be
funny and now they're just political hit
jobs that's well yeah it's clapter and
there's so many colbert colbert coming
up on his show and saying hey hey
republicans are bad yeah
it's like that's not a joke dude i'm not
laughing or him doing the vaccine dance
thing these people have gone nuts i mean
look late night is just by definition a
really disadvantaged formula because a
good stand-up comedian might come out
with an hour every year and then these
late night hosts come out there what
every night with something like 45
minutes of material and so it's not
going to be the best for the most part
even if you have talented writers but
they've stopped trying to be funny
altogether and it literally is just
clapter like you mentioned
they always used to be an escape you'd
watch
showing my age johnny carson and these
other people and i remember you'd hear
his joke about nixon or something but
then he'd get on and people don't watch
these shows to hear about how bad the
republicans are and you know it's the
softest street yeah it is
the the jimmy kimmel why is he having
political debates with people like
marjorie taylor greene on his show yo
can you
hold on guys uh um moon night came out
right it's it's a marvel show here's tim
marvel memeing no no but i mean this
it's all i mean disney's got new shows
why don't you come out and be like you
guys see that new show there's a new
movie with northmen and everyone can
clap and cheer for alex skarsgard and he
can make a joke about it i would say
that if you were conspiracy theorist you
would say that there's a media apparatus
that feeds off of itself if you ever
listen to what colbert says at night
he's kind of picking up on what the
theme of the day was for them going
after
whoever marjorie taylor green so she's
the
pinata for the left for the day and he
kind of finishes it off at the end of
the day and he they used to do that in a
funny way thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you